après le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'est le
prisme qui nous présente sa saison 2012
2013 soit six as milk au sein dans le
kiosque
chanson on a le plaisir d'accueillir
famille et puis la grande dame madame
gréco bien sûr et ensuite humour dans le
style pince-sans-rire gaspard proust
dans les artistes qui sont associés au
projet artistique du prix suit commencer
par pierre note qui est donc auteur
associé au théâtre du rond point et il
s'associe au prisme pour trois ans et on
aura un avant première avant le théâtre
du groupe point sa toute dernière
création les 16 et 17 novembre qui
sortir de sa mère et chad est triste au
cul sortir du sommet ça commence mal sa
fille ni pareil le cri au la chute la
mort et mais bientôt l'héritage les
surprises d'un autre côté la chair des
tristes cul et j'ai mis une vieille
fille une bimbo à la bardot la pâte à
crêpes cher et fils la chair de mes
fesses dans ses crêpes à elle est un
épluche-légumes mais pourquoi faire il
vaut mieux ne pas en dire davantage de
fait ce geste et revient avec deux
chorégraphies pareil dans la même soirée
c'est deux pour le prix d'un chez nous
et il y à 2 77 comme cette femme avec
une énergie extraordinaire une danse
d'ensemble qui nous emmène à ne pas
manquer véritablement a pas manqué
caravan palace pour ceux qui les
connaissent pas eh eh bien ce sont les
standards de jazz des années 40 qui sont
revisités en électro donc voilà ça fait
de l'électro jazz et qui séduit beaucoup
tout lé monde étudiant les grands
lycéens et nous aurons la salle à 900
pour cette occasion là
et boire l'on oublie est entièrement
créés sur une musique de sergei
rachmaninov sur une de ses symphonies et
puis le dernier spectacle est celui de
thomas lebrun que le directeur du centre
chorégraphique national de tours et qui
a mené en chorégraphie mise en espace la
jeune fille et la mort de schubert
m
ouais
le piano bar continue du jazz avant
après les spectacles une nouveauté le
jeudi pratiquement tous les jeudis de
l'année on verra après les vacances
scolaires un happy hour de 18 à 23
heures avec l'âge nouvelle génération
jazz on aura aussi une nouveauté au
piano bar sont les pianos chocolat qui
seront à la suite des spectacles à voir
en famille soit le samedi à la suite du
spectacle de 17 heures dont parlait 18h
ou le mercredi vers les 16h goûter et
découverte de la musique et des
musiciens les mardis du jazz où là on a
renforcé cette notion des mardis du jazz
on a deux leçons d'antoine hervé ils ont
eu beaucoup de succès donc on les a
renouvelées une autour de duke ellington
une autour d'eux des bobek deux
pianistes vraiment à part entière dans
l'univers du jazz qui compte et ensuite
on ne fait un partenariat avec le ciné
celle qui va rouvrir ses portes au tout
début de l'automne et on programme des
ciné jazz dont comptes avec kyle
eastwood on aura six jazz club avec
encore ce que fait la scène jazz
de plus intéressant et notamment un
jeune saxophoniste absolument talentueux
qui s'appelle baptistère bien et
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
tous les rendez vous culturels du moment
à saint quentin en yvelines sur le
kiosque en ligne aux adresses qui
s'affiche alors bon spectacle à tous et
à bientôt
le cachet de la barre